Bem-vindos de volta!
Espero que todos tenham instalado o GHC
e brincado um pouco digitando
expressões.
O que iremos fazer agora é ir
além de simples expressões
e ver como podemos carregar
programas Haskell completos
no GHC.
Em Haskell, programas não são chamados
programas. Normalmente pessoas do Haskell
referem-se a seus códigos
como scripts porque
programas em Haskell são, talvez,
mais curtos do que código normal.
Eu apenas os chamo de programas
Haskell,
mas a linguagem em haskell
é scripts.
Novas funções, se vocês querem
definir um programa completo em Haskell,
defina elas em um
arquivo texto que contenha uma lista de
definições de funções
e este arquivo texto
tenha um sufixo .hs que indica
que é um
arquivo Haskell.
Igual um arquivo HTML tem um
.html sufixo, ou arquivos CSS tem
sufixo .css, ou arquivo Java
tem um sufixo .java,
um arquivo Haskell é chamado
qualquer coisa
.hs. Isso não é obrigatório,
mas é útil que vocês possam ver quando
listarem os arquivos em um diretório
possam ver que
é um script Haskell.
Agora quando vocês
estiverem usando o GHC,
o que vocês fazem é editar o seu
script em uma janela, usando qualquer
editor de sua escolha,
e então sempre que vocês fizerem uma alteração,
carreguem seu
script no seu GHC e comecem
executar expressões.
Então, este é o tipo de fluxo
que usaremos na maioria do curso.
Para coisas simples
isso é o que vocês fazem. Claro, quando estiverem
construindo aplicações comerciais em Haskell
não é assim que vocês fazem.
Vocês compilarão eles em executáveis
standalone,
mas para o propósito deste curso, este
é o fluxo: temos
a janela do editor aberta, temos o
interpretador GHCi aberto
e então carregaremos os scripts.
Neste caso,
criaremos um
arquivo texto test.hs e nele
definimos duas funções.
A primeira:
dobro de x igual a x + x
- faz o que promete -
e então podemos quadruplicar
chamando double de double de x.
Então salvamos aquele arquivo
e iniciamos o
GHCi invocando o ele com
test.hs e agora ambas as bibliotecas
padrão Haskell quanto
as funções quadruple e
double que definimos
no test.hs estarão disponíveis.
Por exemplo, podemos chamar
quadruple de 10
e retornará 40, mas podemos também
ainda chamar todas as funções da
biblioteca padrão. Por exemplo
podemos pegar
o dobro de 2 desta lista. Dobro de 2 é
4, então isto é o mesmo que pegar 4,
então pegamos os primeiros 4
elementos da lista.
O que fazemos agora
é deixar o GHC aberto, retornamos
ao nosso editor e
adicionamos
2 novas definições: uma é factorial
e a outra é average.
Visto que estamos começando aqui,
estamos usando alguma sintaxe
que não introduzimos ainda, então
tenham paciência.
O produto
de 1 até n - esta coisa aqui
é a lista de valores de 1 até n -
e então product é uma função
da biblioteca padrão
que multiplica todos os valores
em uma lista, assim
esta é uma boa definição de fatorial.
Quando queremos calcular a
média
de uma lista nós somamos
todos os elementos - os valores dos elementos -
e então dividimos
pelo comprimento da lista.
Claro, esta não é uma implementação
muito inteligente de média, mas isso
não importa... não estamos
aqui para definir a função average,
estamos fazendo isso para aprender
GHCi. A coisa que estamos usando aqui é
este truque aqui em Haskell
é que quando vocês colocam o nome de
uma função
entre estas aspas simples,
isso torna-se um operador infixo.
Então, se vocês escreverem
x `f` y
isto é realmente apenas "syntactic sugar"
para
f x y. Algumas pessoas gostam destas coisas
como um operador infixo,
outras gostam apenas como um operador
regular
- fica a sua escolha.
Isto é "syntactic convention".
Então isto não é
uma string ou qualquer cosa,
é realmente pegar uma função e retornar
em um operador infixo.
Então no GHCi, chamamos reload
e ele irá ler o arquivo
test.hs, adicione todos os novos vínculos
que definimos
- esta era para o factorial, agora podemos
chamar factorial
e então podemos chamar average também.
Aqui vocês veêm o fluxo:
vocês tem o seu GHCi aberto, seu editor
vocês editam, chamam reload, e assim
podem testar
vocês códigos.
Algums coisas
sintáticas, ou esquisitices em Haskell:
nomes de
funções e paramêtros deve começar com
letra
minúscula.
Se vocês definem uma função, ela deve
ser de qualquer uma dessa formas.
Mas qualquer uma dessas
começam com uma letra
minúscula. Vocês podem usar aspas
simples
se forem muito preguiçoso para
inventar um nome. Isso é
algo que eu muita vezes sinto falta em
outras linguagens, onde eu apenas quero dizer
x prime ou
x double prime, etc.
Se vocês definem um tipo, um tipo
tem que começar com
nome maiúsculo e este é o
motivo. Em Haskell,
os tipos e identificadores
estão em namespaces diferentes e isso
é determinado
se ele começa com um identificador
minúsculo or
maiúsculo. Isso pode ser
confuso se vocês vierem de uma linguagem
diferente como
Java, ou C# ou JavaScript.
Outra coisa é que em
Haskell usamos
uma forma muito suave de notação
húgara.
Se um paramêtro tem um
sufixo s, então por exemplo se
vocês tem um paramêtro nomeado
xs ou ns ou nss,
isso significa uma lista de valores
do tipo x e esta é uma lista de
valores
do tipo n - as vezes o n não corresponde
ao nome
to tipo - mas normalmente quando vocês vêem um
s no final vocês sabem que é uma lista.
Se existir 2 s's no final
- como aqui -
vocês sabem que é uma lista de listas.
Isso é por convenção. Assim, se vocês querem
parecer como programadores Haskell de verdade,
vocẽs deveriam sempre usar esta convenção.
Quando seu paramêtro é uma lista,
ele sempre terminar com s, e normalmente
identificadores Haskeel são curtos
assim, vocês não chamem ele de elements,
vocês chamem de xs.
Uma outra
coisa interessante que Haskell tem em
comum com Python
é que espaços em branco são significantes.
As
regras exatas são bastantes sutis,
mas
estamos apenas usando Haskell
de uma forma bem simples,
então isso
é o sufficient. Se vocês tem uma
sequência de definições - como aqui -
elas todas tem que iniciar na mesma
coluna. Aqui
a, b e c, todas começam
na mesma coluna.
Neste caso aqui,
b tem um espaço no seu lado esquerdo,
assim, agora todas essas definições não começam
na mesma coluna.
Isso está errado!
Ou neste caso, c
e a não iniciam na mesma coluna como b..
também errado.
Espaço em branco é significante em Haskell,
então, certifique-se que todas suas definições
estão alinhadas - isso é chamado de regra de layout.
A regra the layout
existe para evitar escrever
sintaxe desnecessária.
Os caras de Haskell
gostam de escrever isto:
a = b + c where
e então na cláusula where temos
uma lista de definições que
começam todas na mesma coluna e então
d
aqui inicia na mesma coluna como a,
então isso pertence ao mesmo grupo
como a.
Vocês podem escrever isto com
chaves e ponto
e vírgula explicitos
- se vocês quiserem -
mas isso parece muito mais
verboso.
Programadores Haskell gostam de
brevidade,
então, eles usarão com frequência
espaços em brancos.
Isto parece um pouco idiota.
In the Haskell world, when you write code like
this people will look like
"you didn't do enough wax on, wax off".
Here's some GHC commands that are
useful
and I really
invite you to play around with it
When you do the exercises for
subsequent lectures, make sure that you
leverage
GHC or whatever other compiler you use,
to help you. We have seen
reload, but you can also just
load a fresh script.
From the interpreter
you can open the editor, so you can edit
a file with a certain name,
or edit the current script.
This one here is super useful:
it gives the type of an expression and I do
this
all the time - I never write types myself.
I ask what the type is and I go
in the editor and paste in the type.
You definitely should use :?
and that gives you a list of all the
commands
with a small explanation.
Of course,
I hope that you will not use this
last command to quit GHC,
but that you will, for the next
eight weeks,
be constantly using GHC.
There will be a lot of exercises
and the exercises will be on the website.
All these exercises,
you should be able to
do them in any language. You don't
have to use
GHC, but in this case, since this lecture
is about
GHC, they will be
GHC-specific.
In general,
as I said in the very first lecture, this
is a course
about functional programming. It's not a
course about Haskell and it's definitely
not a course about GHC,
but in this specific case the exercises for
this chapter and
for this lecture are on GHCi.
Happy hacking and
see you all next week!